und wieder muss unser wissen über die
nuss korrigiert werden bisher gegen die
wissenschaftlich davon aus dass die
vorfahren der dinosaurier kleines ihre
aufgaben waren das ist aber offenbar
nicht generell der fall habe ich vor
kurzem noch darüber berichtet dass die
stammbäume wohl neu geordnet werden
müssen geht es jetzt an die vorfahren in
kriegszeiten fiction herzlich willkommen
vielen dank an alle zuschauer haben den
letzten wochen einen sensationellen
erfolg möglich gemacht noch nie wurde
klicks um science-fiction so ausgesehen
die lustigen von etwas mehr als 300.000
mitte januar auf jetzt 11 millionen im
monat hoch da wird mehr als in der
erfolgreichen seiten
vielen vielen dank ich freue mich riesig
dass die tägliche berichterstattung so
gut ankommt wir sind so viel dichter an
der entwicklung dran als mit videos die
woche und ich muss ehrlich sagen dass
das tägliche hochladen auch wahnsinnig
spaß macht und ich super gerne so
aktuell recherchiere und moment auch
alle skripte selbst schreibe aber bald
wird es mehr unterstützung gegeben so
dass wir noch besser werden weil dadurch
dass ihr mehr schaut auch etwas mehr
geld bei uns durch die werbeeinnahmen
ankommt dass wir zu 100 prozent in leute
von material vergibt macht das hier aus
leidenschaft ohne etwas von den
einnahmen ab bekommen und da sind eure
kommentare likes und natürlich die abos
eine fantastische motivation 1000 aus
was dafür zu den dinos bisher gegen die
wissenschaftler davon aus dass die
vorläufer der dinos zum beispiel masuchs
oder lack ab geht von war zweibeiner von
der größe eines vogel gültige jetzt hat
ein internationales team völlig von
regina tecan weg wird in tansania
versteigerung eines solchen vogel
flüssigen gefunden dem telegraph
nicht nur darin mit zwei bis drei metern
deutlich größer ist lisa vogel flüssige
bewegten sich eher wie ein krokodil ford
auf vier beinen erlebte vor 245
millionen jahren etwa etwa zehn
millionen jahre vor den ersten - damit
schmeißer die mit jährigen annahmen über
die ursprünge der dinosaurier komplett
über den haufen aus dem kunden ergeben
sich zahlreiche konsequenzen nicht nur
dafür sich auf vier beinen bewegt auch
eine kiefermuskulatur endet bereits der
von dinosauriern oder die beine mit
besonders beweglichen fußgelenken damit
hat sich der technokrat er wie ein
krokodil bewegt und nicht wie heutige
laufvögel der fund führt jetzt eine
bisher weitgehend unerforschte lücke war
es einfach keine versteinerung aus
dieser zeit gab
jetzt muss auch die entwicklung vor den
dinosauriern neu bewertet werden sie
scheinen viel komplexer zu sein als
bisher angenommen auf zu diesem thema
hat sich euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden
wenn er dazu kein video verraten wollte
dann durch mehr hier genau ein abo aufs
auge und je mehr einen auf die glocke
hier geht es zum video zum thema
bisherigen dinosaurier forschung
komplett falsch darauf klicken und bis
dann bleibt dran